I will send it down this afternoon deals
with a key dimension of energy anybody
about what happened in Ukraine earlier
this year and about the very serious
energy security questions that not only
ukraine evolved of Europe is facing and
I'm happy to say that we have two people
on the panel just will enlighten us
about this our first speaker is Adrian
Karen Pinsky a graduate of Columbia
University somebody of Ukrainian polish
background as the press informs us and
for a number of years the director of
freedom house in New York City
Washington and rupesh it now the
founding director of an foundation
called the Ukrainian circle Sorry Sorry
the orange circle something that we all
plays great hopes on in our second
speaker is a new friend gaya tha geo bye
who is the vice director of a spin-off
one might call it polish national gas
company which is forced to separate its
operations as a result of getting into
the European Union and as I said the
topic is energy and energy security and
I will invite Adrian to
make his presentation first if it's all
right we're going to have the questions
than answers going from the table if you
don't mind I'll address you seated so
this conference I'm trying to stick to
the conference theme say that the
conference doesn't need provide a very
good opportunity to examine and to think
about how countries of Central and
Eastern Europe can participate on a
range of strategic economic and security
issues but it also allows us to examine
how additional content can now be
infused into the existing mechanisms of
cooperation in Ukrainian division grad
countries on one hand and what some
refer to as the Old Europe on the other
and the fish crab cognitive process and
the bishop root word of course the
central mechanism for helping push
forward the process of entry first
engine air own into the European Union
but i think you know i don't want to I
think we have to be very clear that the
fishing rod group is more of a sense of
cooperation among world leaders in a
very dynamic and existing institutional
process there are meeting several times
a year irregularly very general
statements or issue it is not what I
would say it's an intermittent rather
than a consistent structure and I think
that is as a tribute ukraine on
holovision
tempted to launch similar i would say
intermittent flexible structures through
Richard hopes to realize certain geo
political interests and these include
the wrong the Georgia Ukraine other by
John entity and secondly whether the
newer entity Ibaka she was more
discussion yesterday and I guess morning
the community of Democratic choice which
really brings States from the Baltic the
black of the Black Sea and the Caspian
together in a in a in a process which is
have one reading with several heads of
state and foreign ministers but which I
know that the foreign minister pursuit
is very interested in enemy I would
argue that the community of Democratic
choice blood fishing rod and like wrong
can now be infuse contribu now infused
with great of specific command should
become mechanisms which to engage the
rest of you on the issue of energy
security it seems to me that these are
flexible enough structures flexible
enough processes that can help create a
certain kind of momentum in debate we
know that it will be a g8 meeting under
Russia's chairmanship
energy security we know that given the
way energy spirit is likely to be
discussed it will be when I don't think
we're going to count on very radical new
departures from you promises from a
ruffle for example at that meeting
although I think there will be a lot p
or extended as those of us who have been
reading the recent Putin Abed's
understand rather than read including
soft beds who would be better off
reading his doctoral dissertation where
which rejected was excellently
summarized by Martha all comment is
available on the Carnegie Endowment
website it's okay treated about a year
and a half ago for the Baker Center in
Houston mainly focused on oil but
nevertheless extreme extremely valuable
paper but I think we all know that the
nexus of energy and democracy as it was
referred to yesterday is now extremely
important the community the countries
that we are talking about are either
nascent democracies or countries on the
road to democracy Sullivan are already
rooted in Europe but all of them have
economies that are highly dependent and
the Russian interruption of the gas flow
beginning of the new you're really
signaled I would argue a new tube moment
it's at the same time at the moment of I
would say both of concern and unease on
many countries but it is also a moment
haces filled with opportunities
filled with geopolitical opportunity
it's filled with political diplomatic
opportunity it's also filled with
commercial art because I think that here
the Nexus of those is extremely
important whenever there is a landmark
shift in the way countries think about
something as crucial as energy energy
supplies and energy extraction there are
opportunities for new ways of
approaching those create new great and
grand products we can involve both the
old actors that have their subtle place
in the international energy sphere and
new actors that are dropping for
position there's plenty of money
floating around for these kinds of
things with it was a degree of focus and
leadership that can be given body by
these by the leaders of these structures
and the engagement of some of the
European countries and European leaders
to the West who may be concerned I think
we can accomplish a lot so in some sense
I think what we have to do is move
there's a concept if it without vision
rod and wishy-washy grande which is the
sort of the parrises and the Romans
who've been wanting to be the record way
of providing providing energy let's just
remind everyone that the Russian gas
issue gas consumption globally will be
rising by about sixty percent over the
next 20 or 25 years from its current
levels around the world of countries
like China
which only now or three percent
depending on the use of natural gas but
their energy needs will be clearly
trying to tap into that market and
creating greater a greater demand and
the real pressure that has to be asked
is not simply a question of is it in the
interest of Europe and is it in the
interests of than you know the countries
and neighboring Russia that in effect
that the monopoly on gas from Central
Asia and and Russia deep of primarily in
the hands of the Russian state
particularly in the period where Russia
has shown yet again that it that it has
a desire as its energy policy for the
year twenty 20 shows us to ensure with
written and spoken about that there is a
clear zhu zhu political power projection
component in the thinking of Putin and
the Russian leadership in the use of
energy so Germany as you may know is
about forty percent dependent on Russian
gas on this is rising Ukraine is
depending on how you slice it is about
you know thirty percent dependent on
Russian gas but it's really about
seventy to eighty percent dependent
because the Russians as they showed in
this latest crisis we're not just
controlling the flow of Russian gas in
the dispute but they were blocking
Turkmen gas as well and I think that was
what was one of the great elements of
pressure Italy thirty percent turkey
sixty-three percent France or as France
have a famous slogan and friends we
don't have oil we have ideas so Frances
only 20
I nuclear energy slovakia is a hundred
and three percent it pretty that it
imports more pressure Dave actually that
it could soon finland one hundred
percent bulgarian ninety-four percent
lithuania 84 greece 8174 in austria and
so on and so on there's a huge
dependency in these states states and
structures that dependency is fine if
you look at the russian low and should
be an important and will be the crucial
source of supplies but i do think that
the issues that the that the vision gran
countries ukraine a community of
democratic towards members on georgia
and others who had felt a big bump a big
tremor as it were i'm not quite enough
cap strata earthquake with this big
tremor at the beginning of the year I
wanted to be concerned about is whether
Russia should be in a sense of the
Donald an exclusive arbiter of energy
and this opens up the entire plane of
energy diversification for discussion at
international forum and I believe that
these three groups these three
cooperative processes Guam viscera and
the community of Democratic choice can
the major drivers in engaging other
democracies and engaging with the United
States in changing the parameters so I
think we'll hear more concretely about
specific project adesso brought it which
is a piece of this overall also that
there are what there is a lot of talk in
recent days post January in the US and
in other countries about creating
alternative routes alternative sources
diversifying
energy energy efficiencies energy fuel
alternatives and one idea which again
from the point of view I know of
high-ranking US officials is gang again
credence is the revival of the
trans-caspian energy part 1 there is my
understanding a consortium that is ready
to take this project forward provided
that tremendous time could be interested
in increasing its its extraction and its
applause and bypassing rush on moving
through channels that would go through
the caucuses of three turkey into some
Northern Europe Central East Central
Europe energy center grid so one route
possibly to be in another week possibly
up through Bulgaria and into remaining
why are prizes I think it's self-evident
while this project is as important
because it would create a greater
flexibility and a greater independence
on the part of in the case of natural
gas turkmenistan international behavior
and second because they do have
alternative sources of
consumers similarly be the case with
Kazakhstan in the case of both natural
gas and and another issue that I think
is should be part of this discussion is
the return to nuclear energy initiatives
in some of the European countries there
is a environmental or a political
objection to these but in other
countries there is not there are players
on the energy seen that want obviously
the energy the nuclear power industries
systems of the structure whose corporate
structures would be very interested in
seeing larger projects and water dishes
a hydroelectric power in Georgia has
been an issue that has been discussed
Georgia only uses about producing it has
his uses only ten percent of its fiber
electric capacity does not connect into
a sophisticated grid grid good export
those content needs the revival of a
Norway to Poland pipeline a project that
had been put on the back burner when
Poland was hoping to be part of the
northern route of Russian Russian energy
that's another another another theme
that that needs to be raised discussed
cran as an agricultural state has long
wait so a bottle fuels and so on and the
more important thing the overall picture
is really what but people in the
industry might call harmonizing
downstream and upstream development and
investment because you have to kind of
produce supply has to meet demand has
meet infrastructure and these are rather
complex things that involve the
intermediary role of of states and it
seems to me that I don't believe you're
going to get that kind of a mechanism
purely at the level of these great
players and the United States which
probably revanche to push a more dynamic
program through the g8 is probably not
going to it's probably going to fall for
it with what I would like to see in
terms of Russian commitments pressure I
think Russia exceeding to the WTO on
conditions that it accepts some of the
key provisions of the European energy
charter if not to sign up with the
Charter to sign on to the provisions on
not walking third party economic
relationships of adjudication process of
them and the like all of these kinds of
issues can be resurrected and not
believe we have the in this intermittent
diplomatic structure which can be I
would sort of put it employed in the
face of the traditional Europe of
traditional approaches and I believe
that in this this sense there can be a
new mission for a new focus on grow a
fishing rod community
choice and the wrong I think I'll I'll
end with that and there's this is such a
large and important important copy but I
would say that diversifying the sources
of energy are is not purely a reaction
to run by diversifying energy sources
from Central Asia and through
alternative sources I mean Connor is as
we all know the Senate largest source of
energy Russia has 27 or so percent of
the world's supply cotton tiny
congressman in prison of the world's
natural gas supplies it has problems of
distance but that means more focus on
lipid but finding these additional
environments beyond your own beyond
Russia engaging central asia creating
connections and infrastructure to move
those countries and to enmesh them in to
the west rather than to leave them in
the monopoly of russian supply and
possibly tempt them to open up to what
will serve with me in welcoming market
to these all these are they extremely
important agenda items for all of europe
and i would say that we that if the
international community can succeed a
diversified a bit more not dramatically
but to some degree they
the energy transiting countries and
reduce russia's dominance in that fuel
it will actually reduce rifles
temptation to try to play that kind of
the geo-political map so it would be for
the good of Western Europe if Eastern
I'm going to invite panels we have to
move to the ejector I represent I hope
you'd an operator of Polish gas
transmission system the company ecole
des system pretty scary was breaking up
for a few months ago in the probably
well known to all of you or at least
most of most of you and how we should
address company for the monopoly company
dealing with all aspects of oil and gas
and you to European be wreck-it forget
and the transmission division of the
potc has been separated from the company
and establishes a new independent
company and that was I would like to
thank her organizers for inviting me and
to have it on it will be here and to
present about a few marks concerning a
gas gas industry in Poland and also in
the whole Europe it is obvious meetin
hearing now there's not enough time to
present the problem very stoic and in
every detail as probably so you know I'm
an engineer so I will try to focus
mainly on a technical aspects technical
iwi will give you numbers and graphs and
I will really try to leave the
congregation to a respective experts
which I can see quite a few only between
audience so although I will try not to
make any political or even economical
remarks just trying to focus on
technical aspects I will shortly
presented and prospectively in the all
around the world as I'm working in the
gas industry so I will concentrate on
the gas as a lecturer 21st century then
we were so much truly
after talking the gas promised a giant
energy company in the world to finish
with the main problems nowadays which is
security of energy supply I will
concentrate on security of gas supply
important and well if I can in the whole
Europe so let's stop this and described
the enemy problems the info comedians is
not the it's not the subject of this
presentation but of course it is not
possible to discuss energetic evolution
safety security of the Europe without
basic knowledge about at least
tendencies in evolution of Bloor global
primary energy depending on the sources
and evaluated trends is possible to
present many different scenarios of the
world primary energy consumption in
future often with extreme projections
some of them are with the coal and the
other ways get gas consider domination
in future foil primary energy market of
course I'm working gas industry so it is
why I presented your this scenario with
day
creation but affect the the projections
of long term forecasting of energy
consumption is a well very fascinating
quite safe job because as a matter of
fact it's quite similar to a
fortune-telling from coffee grounds
because well if you look at the period
of time happy tears one is not as
possible future my focus this Sherlock
okay so but I had to be serious the fact
is during last 20 years the welds called
the world has increased over sixty-two
percent but they also truth is that the
same period of time the whole energy
demand has increased 75% and definite
robust four hundred and twenty percent
so it's much higher than for call it is
why i put this scenario consumption of
natural gas worldwide increases in the
forecast by an average two-point-three
percent annually after the year twenty
twenty-five compared with projected
annual growth rate of one point nine
percent for oil consumption and to
present for coal consumption so when we
look at the graph of projected to
natural gas consumption up to the year
2025 it is quite sure the draw of
natural gas and an ecological source of
energy is going to be more and more
significant last year's let's say plus
decay
the average annual energy demand
increase is one from some sources even
up to 1.5 percent there are annually so
what is important in any scenario we
take into account whether went the skull
over the gas domination the truth is
that the two largest countries into
nervous countries in the world to
mention in India China the energy
consumption per capita is extremely low
it's less than twenty percent of average
worldwide consumption which means that
there's a great potential of increase in
future not only the total energy but
also natural gas image let's look at the
energy structure on the regular original
basis and in the red color is marked the
visible group so 2 Republic Hungary
Poland and Slovakia also i put in the
table ukraine russia your say as the
countries of interest during this
seminar and the world energy information
as you can see a big energy consumption
structure in mention countries and also
in in holland world it is for sure that
in poland and enjoyed republic then God
still has a major position and her white
is well I just say it is because the non
domestic resources of a call we still
have quite a future resources of sorts
of coal in Poland and chair as for the
other countries and also all over the
world and the gas contribution to the
energy balance it's much higher than in
orange Republic the largest increases in
natural gas consumption worldwide are
projected for traditional economics for
Eastern Europe and the former Soviet
Union countries natural gas used in
mention areas will expand by the
projected sixty-three percent up to the
year 2025 and in the country's when I
throw gas markets avoid Amish
consumption of national gas is the
projected by more modest annual average
one-point-six percent so let's move to
guess from all Isaac you need to go it's
quite amusing natural gas is all usually
projected as to be the fastest growing
component of what primary energy
consumption so while one may ask why yes
because this ritual is very issue 8 NH
few mountains it's very flexible it
burns if I can
and it's plentiful so the 21st century
will be sure witness dramatic new
efficiencies in web-based combustion
technologies we are also in the advent
of an entirely new era namely the
hydrogen technologies so called the
nican age can serve as a bridge towards
hydrogen and solar energy and talking
about hydrogen error it is wet to
mention that the best source of hydrogen
is of course natural gas let's look
let's move to Europe and look at the
energy structure in Europe well i would
like to concentrate on my own country
poland as we can see on the blue sphere
the initial assumption in poland is
rather low compared to the other
european countries and also the gas
consumption guess factor in the total
energy consumption is also low so we
have a great potential for further
increase and also quite a long way to
reach the mention before ningn error
okay let's talk about gas resources all
around world the numbers in the circle
these are a number of guest resources
explaining the how Howard the lodge the
resources are as you can notice from
this slide the gas resources natural gas
resources around the world are allocated
very unevenly mainly in Russia and in
Middle East just follow the bikini
countries and middle east countries
comprised together over seventy percent
of the world's natural gas resources and
from mentioned just two countries Russia
and Iran together account for over fifty
percent of the world's natural gas
resources when you have the structure
and commercial gas reserves in the world
pro12 natural gas reserves are estimated
to have the projected gas consumption
for next 60 70 years try projections are
for a recorded phone call and it is
forecasted to have even up to 120 years
event but here we have to bear in mind
that the significant amount of that
that's resources to mind still
undiscovered and additionally there are
so called uncle unconventional resources
with large deposits of methane hydrates
to be truly tragic for those who don't
who don't know what a methyl hydrate it
is a compound of Megan and water in a
solid state located mainly under the
bottom of oceans it is estimated that
the reserves overcome the reserves often
he drank many drinks or welcome three
times coal and oil potential resources
and can cover God demand for something
like written in red 500 years which
renders natural gas into almost
inexhaustible source of energy when you
look at the inanimate many of Europe but
not only you can see the main directions
of death experts from the largest fields
of gas in the world and from this
picture it is quite clear that the
greatest volume of gas the Sun numbers
on the picture the new greatest volume
of gas is exported from Russia to Europe
later on if it with you today's
consumption of natural gas in Europe and
made in Europe it is projected that
the Russian resources can cover
something like eight years devout but we
have to bear in mind consumption is
still increasing all the time so we
started to talk about Russian resources
let's move to Castro and total you know
the Russian gas projects that company
was established over 10 years ago in
February 93 the major shareholder of the
company mistake having little less than
1% of shares the company's core
activities of gas exploration production
transportation processing and marketing
gastrin produces about ninety percent of
Russian gas and in the year two thousand
and five last year it was about 6,600 to
billions of cubic meters when God from
controlling almost sixty percent of
Russian gas reserves and it provides
about twenty percent openings to the
federal budget also because of all of it
is responsible for about eight percent
of Russian a GED with about fifty
billion dollars optimization if we're to
mention that regard from is the sixth
largest company and the largest company
producing gas in the world god brochure
in wellness production is about twenty
percent produced gas is delivered to six
to eight regions of Russian Federation
but also to 27 frame countries well this
is me in front of gastrin I during
every time I was discussing with some of
you about half year ago I had a chance
to visit gastro it was quite an
experience I was well let's hook the
world prison almost in the gut from
stress workers it's very nice place but
that's all I can say about my visit okay
so just to follow would welcome the
company the hundred percent founder of
over 60 subsidiary's but it also
participated in authorized capital of
almost half night Russian and foreign
companies apart from gas companies from
illness companies from the others from
death sectors just to mention such a
thing like football talk well known than
in Petersburg Omega concern a gastro
media as a year already mentioned the
Gospels major shareholder is the stage
directly or through Russian companies a
proud and privates their frame companies
on skype nice piece of the shareholder
spoil gospel is continuously tightening
its international connections with
Europe not only directly thanks to all
gas resources but also due to
partnership and cooperation with many
mentioned that the shown on the slide
gasps major gas company
say in Europe here is the main gas
transportation here the main gas
transportation pipelines in Russia
gastro participate in a number of
international top priority gas
transportation projects including
so-called export routes yeah a Europe
blue stream from Russia Turkey mentioned
by Adrian Esmeralda remember also the
notion of early European or also called
baltic sea transportation hood and also
customer of course takes part in a
number of domestic transmission of
projects from all the transportation
routes transporting natural gas from
Russia to Europe about eighty-five
percent run through Ukraine and it is
the shortest gas gas transmission road
from Russia to Europe okay so it is
clear from all what I said that Gazprom
and you know all know perfectly well
definitely being politicians economic
working on economic korea the gospel is
not only joined by the gas giant but
also accompanied deeply engaged in
business financial structure of European
energy market but Gotham is facing many
many serious problems first we all know
that domestic gas prices and also prices
for former civilian countries allowed
market prices only because of that gas
pumps losing about two hundred million
dollars per year per year another
serious problem is a problem of
unaccomplished progress it makes these
are together it makes about fifty
percent of product of reproduction just
to make it more more clear for your
moment in fifteen percent of brother
offer total production it is five times
more than polish Iowa natural gas
consumption okay the next problem it's a
transportation system it is very
exploited and some expert to keep saying
that it's explained it in over sixty
percent and it varies for investment
investments it is very difficult to need
to keep working system inaudible
condition and it could be not very
expensive to do so but for assistant
such condition gastro has to stand about
11 billion dollars per yet the I could
just keep talking about problems that
was saying anyway because of mentioning
not mentioned problems gasps comics in
depth for something between projected to
be sucking up to 30 billion dollars also
gasps promise not competitive talking
about this production let's mention a
canada cost of less production and when
you compare it to when we compare it to
prices of destron gas production in
Gotham it is twice more expensive just
to become competitive it is estimated
that Gotham needs about 60 billion
dollars and of course custom has no that
much money if we try to book all the
dimension songs together well one may
say that God from kaskus but from all
you know there is not enough investments
in geological exploration and
development of gas fields in Russia
those mainly love belong to the gastrin
the end interracial research to
production remains approximately the
same as now even quite dear future by
the a 2030 gospel is going to face the
most serious problem which means that
the gospel is going to say without gas
and again to manage all these problems
the gas from its money maker
and many great money what it means for
us for Europe it only means that with
very smart and long-term politics Europe
has a great power in hands if we look at
the structure gasps props gas export to
Europe I put it in red the Visigoths
group countries and on the other table
day Ukraine well what we can see that
during the last few years there is a
slight decrease of a graphics card to be
secured group countries it is no
disabled but that's nothing for custom
because they have huge plans of an
expansion to Western markets the only
power brick requested they say that by
the year 2010 they are going to cover up
to ten percent of the whole British
market but their destination gas markets
are not only separate countries but also
the whole European Union and even your
say-so actually you're not going to eat
universe you have already mentioned on
this slide is shown the Europeans
on Russian gas but first what I'm going
to do I am going to make clear that
so-called Russian gas it's not only gas
from Castro but also from other
companies and former self and former
Soviet sub attila countries but here is
the point for people from Europe due to
political dependences you have business
link shares in companies ownership of
transportation networks and so on as a
matter of fact in Europe we may assume
that so-called Russian gas is Gospels
gasps as you can see in the picture for
physical group and former Soviet Union
countries the dependency on Russian gas
is very very high compared to the
average European Union dependency which
is about forty percent as you can see in
my country Poland our dependency is
about fifty three percent mainly due to
quite high domestic national gas
production compared to the other
European and focus on a trillion
countries okay so let's go to the
security problems let's recall some
recent effects unknown februari 2004
Russia was in gas conflict with the
white Russia at the transit pipeline
from
trance throw pillows so turning off the
gas flow had immediate effect ended how
you almost home Europe in Poland on
februari 18th we experienced gas supply
was less about thirty five percent
compared to their natural normal supply
and the next day it was even as high as
fifty percent very recently for software
january twenty six weeks during more or
less and less situation it was due to
the financial dispute over russia supply
of gas to Ukraine Gazprom reduce the
amount of natural gas transmitted to
European Union member states here oh
Christ transmission system and some
countries of European Union experienced
absolutely percent loss of the normal
supply in home when we experienced about
second percent loss the very recent a
problem it was the second decade of the
January this time it was soon well I
believe so mainly due to to climate very
cold winter in Russia and
also in the other countries in the whole
Europe this time and a natural gas
supplies Ukrainian again have been
limited basically this cute the first
one in the Google Russia why Russia then
between Russia and Ukraine dispute
between third countries directly touched
another of the European culture members
it is due to mutual dependence between
Russia kiseop lawyer and Ukraine is a
key transit country and also European
Union as the key consumer let's remember
the average European dependency on
Russian gas is about forty percent right
now following international energy
agency if there is no major change in
European energy policy dimension of age
dependency on the Russian gas will
increase in European Union up to seventy
percent in the year 12 2020 so let's put
the question is there any chance to
change it unfortunately so far the
European Union do not have any
collective and cohesive x approach on
energy supply there is a chance that due
to recent and owning up Naga recent
problems with Russian gas supply to many
countries it will move European Union
towards a common energy policy in the
meantime some countries try to achieve
security of energy
yes supply individually s so far the
approach to this issue is considered and
discussed many on national level let's
see an example which is meant to support
next apply a security but on the
contrary on the long distance it can
even increase the dependency on Russian
gas what I am talking about is the NOC
European gas pipeline in May which meant
to connect Western Europe with various
gas jobs it will deliver Russian natural
gas to Western Europe avoiding trial
trusted states along its route the
pipeline will run under the waters of
Baltic Sea from a pretoria by to the
cost of Germany and it is projected that
then it will go across Germany to other
ones and then to Great Britain it is
also planned to that pipeline will
correspond to the legacy to consumers in
Sweden the plan is to build to parallel
the pipeline legs each about 1,200
kilometres long with the annual capacity
55 billion cubic meters the first
pipeline is supposed to all stop
operation in the air 2010 so here are
yielders want throughout the main
question what does present in energy
security by recognition it is to secure
the necessary amount of energy at
reasonable prices for sustainable
growth and social development fulfilling
and elemental requirements let's go move
to my country Poland and see what
activities are important the moments
taken or on the discussion to fulfill
the technician so we are talking about
them also mentioned by a vm 75 of the
yellow it was planned from the very
beginning there was rumor for many years
about it by now it should be in
operation now we start to discuss it but
I don't believe is going to be any
future for this project we are
discussing the project of an LNG there
are two ng projects of terminal one
close to the city called dice seen on
the big to the other one on the west
coast close to stretching from time to
time we go back to the discussion about
destiny great rolled away also mentioned
by and by in a dream back from all I
know it it has no future because it's
not only the probe technical problem
it's also geopolitical problems and
another project nabucco project is not
only Poland but it's also the whole
Europe where we
there's no a lot of talk about another
pipeline the Nabucco is named for plants
of Austrians energy companies of iranian
and central asian gas reserves the bikes
are meant to cross the turkey and Balkan
countries bypassing Russia the
construction of four billion euro
pipeline is expected to commerce this
year but we can imagine that it will
take 80 s now considering many many
years to do portable power to be a
viable alternative so let's now move to
from Poland we started with an a buca so
let's fall of the European approach to
energy security first of all we have to
follow the ideal model we should follow
the young
second gas supply which means that there
should be minimum volatility gas supply
sources with maximum one set of the
power supply from each of them and that
the gas storages should make up for few
months worth of possible chocolates to
be more precise the definition says that
it should be ten percent of an annual
consumption so knowing it I would like
to ask the question one had a viable
alternatives for Europe so all right
direction many many times
diversification of pipeline systems
guess storages and alternative gas
supply sources to mention describe
chocolate before Nabucco pipeline and
really very very viable alternative
which is energy experts and condensing
gas trophy shows also agree that there's
a great potential in a liquefied gas the
apt or isn't it has been extremely
expensive and therefore an economical
that lopez rodriguez and first of all
all a complaint infrastructure becoming
cheaper and cheaper also it's becoming
quite attractive alternative the powers
in Europe one is for sure the rest
effect that were Russia unidos its
energy reserves mainly gas reserves to
the political instrument it is also
clear that Europe needs a common policy
on security and energy supply probably
all of you may have read the book when
you were young and beautiful you're
still young the book all three
musketeers by
Reba recently our polish prime minister
also read this book definitely set
probably the most up-to-date sentence
describing the solution to European
energy problems and the sentence was
Europe's energy musketeers must stand
together even more recent on februari
24th which is just two days ago polish
Prime Minister send energy security
proposals to authentic countries not
only from European Union but also from
NATO the principles of the proposals are
simple and similar as in aid of
solidarity and real support to capture
with emergency problems pending inner
energy to compute the proposed energy
security pact it will be necessary to
build common systems of death storages
and it is huge in the proposals they
will be used on non commercial basis on
emergency also it will it will be
necessary to build inner connection of
transmission networks not only progress
but also for oil and electricity but the
recent and hockey news from today
morning in your European boring that as
a matter of fact probably there is no in
no future for adoption of of this
proposal energy security pact why well
just two countries from Europe to
mention i will mention also going to God
I will germany and france they already
want surprise look they already
declared I mean not very official
adjusted for comment to the project to
the project polish project that they are
not interested in with Germany no
problem they are thinking about Baltic
Sea pipelines so they feel circu they
are not interested in any rocket pack
with France's different story we all
know the story so they still not
necessity need to discuss but what's
more even European Union well just ad
hoc stated and it's not interested in so
so European Commission so European
Commission even if they declare that
they are deeply interested in though
they are not they it going to be very
serious problem with adoption this
proposal possibility of adoption this
proposal because they are not compatible
with so-called green book which is going
to be published very soon green book is
also taking into account the problem of
energy security and the European Union
Solidarity on this subject but what is
mentioned it's only one problem it's
going to be solidarity and security on
information level that the countries are
going to inform each other about about
possibility possible threats and of gas
shortages so what we can say I can see
personally it's my private opinion that
is going to bed
discussion about any european union
based pac---- and solidarity security
energy supply policy compressive and /
and so leader but when we are talking
about physical physical group and
ukraine there is much more possible that
we will reach some short i invite
anybody to ask a question or comment
i'll start yesterday we heard it from
the Georgians and maybe something that
we can continue today a little bit
because they'd really brought it up and
this is better did a wonderful job about
it a question of energy and democracy
combined energy and democracy as a
combination and these god and the
concept of the community of democratic
choice of guam and so on various Eastern
European Central European entities that
have been found over time whose double
role might be both democracy energy
hoverin someone to comment on with the
Georgian ambassador or ECM said
yesterday that it's possible to do both
and that in fact if this is the cement
that can repeat those numbers isn't much
of that gas coming out of the Central
Asian community and if it is isn't it
strange that that if there were greater
democracy ironically there would also be
a greater transparency in terms
the energy issue and greater supply
through various routes that don't ask
the necessary go through Russia so is
there can we begin to see that energy
also ties in with probably what's going
to be the next subject which is about
democracy can we've tried the two or
those are those two mutually exclusive
that one is so involved with
self-interest that it really can't be
can't play democracy the first time in
point about you know the Central Asian
countries do not have if you combine
status and Kazakhstan and Turkmenistan
natural gas they do not have that still
selected five percent four percent of
what
has together so they're not an exclusive
all the issues that were advocated in
the excellent presentation where
diversification storage alternative
sources as many different varieties not
being overly dependent on either one
source or one supplier so really I think
what you're talking about is adding the
architecture that is that is a Russian
international I started after that
doesn't create a monopoly for supply and
distribution and I think it helps
promote of Ukraine if Ukraine Ukraine
will become part of the Russian
distribution system or it can be only
you know a part of a more diversified
system and I think at that point the
Ukrainian had his strength Ukraine could
not play the hand of cutting off every
key to Europe because it was dependent
on because it couldn't shut down the
supplies to Europe as a threat and in
speed with Russia Russia could shut off
the gas from both menaced an end and
from Russia Princip rain hat doesn't
have an energy part of that kind to play
and cranes best solution is to take
advantage of its event of its assets
limited assets his storage capacity it
has the largest natural gas per
passenger that had to be expand other
countries would need to expand this I'm
happy you know the formula without bond
in the Polish plan is the beginning but
I also think that in a sense it's a free
brains interests it's quite interesting
that
the rejection of a European Union or
NATO conglomerate to resolve this
problem if it doesn't get off the ground
actually opens up the possibilities of
Ukraine of Azerbaijan of Georgia and
other countries participating in this in
this common policy some substance and
one disappointment that I had with Prime
Minister carts and carriages proposal
was that it excluded the vulnerable
transit countries I'm so sorry I know
that the proposals represented pathetic
two countries that not the Ukraine have
no idea why yeah exactly i'm i think
about these are issues they could be
worked out and it in dialogue i think
that they you know and i think there's a
huge kiss on my by the point my basic
point is that this is this is an issue
where diplomacy and commercial interests
are married we're talking about
incredible new investment opportunities
and different ways of doing business and
I think you know there are the set
players and we saw all the Andes and the
Roar gases and gazda Francis of the
world that are and i needed to extend to
norway is very integral T and intimately
involved in the
there are also important tires that are
not part of that pie and there are
important midsize players that want to
become a bigger so I don't think so
these are these are ideas for an
interesting merger of the private sector
the Europe that is interested in new
approaches could could could go a long
way but I think you know the more
complicated issues the more like the new
democracies require stability and
diversity of energies of law but that
means they have to enter into
relationships with less-than-stellar
countries when we saw where the gas is
coming from these are not gas and oil
are coming from mainly not politically
free and not liberal liberal democracies
so the only but the idea is to in a
sense to divide and rule 22 divided the
supplies the roots of the sources and a
half as many of them diversified as you
possibly can matica that limits
there are risks of their of their
intruding into technical question
voltage by 90 but maybe you are
competent stop I wonder if the gas
producing could be stopped effectively
because I happen to meet in some
articles that the wheel which pumps the
gas can be blocked so this gas should be
Isaac transported or stored in some
storage or push Basin into the air so
you know this cutting the gas supply is
a double-edged weapon and so I do not
read about it they got Russians toward
the question captain well to a certain
extent you can limit the gas production
but you cannot stop it completely
because it's not safe so what you can
want you can really do if your what
don't want to send the gas to put the
gas from the hill to the storages or to
the transmission system to distribute it
all around well whatever Network it is
the national or international well you
have some how to send it to bigger so
it's a it is what I mentioned
unaccounted for guess we've got from up
to fifteen percent it is this as a part
of it is just the gas lost due to
limitations of the production it means
of to spend
you teach you much more yes that's it of
course because then we can achieve the
bad a better and usage of the last we
have could not hear all your
presentations but he was present final
part when you some with lot of gas a bit
pessimistic about the future in this
proposal from the government Putin and I
would be more honest with because first
the common energy policy first of all is
on the EU agenda since 40 years he took
40 years to agree on nothing for example
for example directive arm what is Tory
took the same time let's the toy starts
of their competition for member states
energy sector in Germany and in France
is much more worth yearly than polish
national trouble so for this government
to react just one day or gas in few
hours to the proposal which is
revolutionary in in taking energy issue
people died some some time but we are in
a good position that we we initiate we
initiated the discussion on issues and
we make welcome the present situation
with with gas the diversification and
the supply to follow and two other
Central European countries he's the
result of many years not paying
attention to the issue and this also
punch government could change the plans
i can remember three to four times in
last 15 years gen or even even more so
my argument that it will
sometime in the meantime we should work
on the issue of diversification new new
sources of energy that's important that
discussion stop that Russians one again
made you rotten to eat real security
issue and that's important and that's
very good message that that in the
states are European states are much more
sensitive now to the issue and this will
be a very good discussion for European
Commission the grid book is a is a
beloved child just delivered juras
delivered soon and and and you want them
to the Father ideal today to say to send
it signed in a project so I understand
the direction from NATO from mega burger
you this much more promising yeah okay
ready to sting to reflect on it so far
for some sometime okay I agree with your
letter maybe I was too pessimistic maybe
the project will develop interchain not
yours fugitive has to take time but also
the project has to be discussed much
more I've changed probably from
technical point of view and because one
have to realize that this this proposal
is that all other countries signing your
energy pack as opposed to to support the
country in a energy agency you have to
remember that it is not going to be one
country european individual in energy
emergency because if we remember the
transfer gas transportation system
structure if gazprom Russians decide to
turn off valve well it's not a review on
country many countries in Europe former
Soviet Union countries Ukraine or
whatever all the way transit countries
are going to little certain to somehow
experience their loss of gas delivery
thank you very much for all time